Whether its Mozart, Joni Mitchell,
Adele or newcomers like Frank Ocean,
music is powerful and has existed in all
cultures throughout history.
But why do humans find music
so addictive and pleasurable?
At its core, music is the combination of audio
frequencies and intricate patterns
floating through the air and
clashing together in your ear.
Much like your eyes process light, your ears process waves of sound
and trigger a state of excitement
and sometimes pleasure in your brain.
Humans experience pleasure from many
stimulants such as food, sex and drugs.
But because many of these stimulants
are necessary for human survival
the body has created a system
in which it rewards you for achieving them.
What's really happening is a release
of a neurotransmitter in the brain called dopamine.
Dopamine is a chemical responsible for
making you feel good.
When dopamine is released following a reward
such as a delicious meal or winning the lottery,
the neurotransmitter causes a feeling
of pleasure and satisfaction.
Drugs, such as cocaine, take advantage of this
pathway by increasing the amount of dopamine,
or rather, preventing its removal,
causing continual stimulation of your neurons,
which creates intense moments of pleasure.
Music has the ability to create
a state of arousal
causing pupils to dilate
blood pressure to rise,
and the brain to fire in
auditory, movement and emotional regions.
And even though music does not have
a direct survival benefit,
this emotional reaction causes a release of
the feel good chemical dopamine.
Though the exact evolutionary reasoning is unclear,
the amazing fact remains,
music chemically alters our body
and makes us feel great.
And in the same way that a drug
induced dopamine surge leaves you craving more,
music becomes addictive.
The dopamine tells your body it was rewarded
and creates the desire to seek out more.
Even though music enjoyment is entirely subjective and
intertwined with cultural and personal experience
The chemical effects remain consistent
amongst the human race,
a perfectly natural drug of happiness.
Got a burning question you want answered?
Ask it in the comments or on facebook
and twitter.
And subscribe for more weekly
science videos.